(shout out to previous editor who made first 7 m)
I just took a shit
And there is this thing
And I wanted to vlog
it going up my butthole
* vlog music *
Hey, how's it going bros
I'm on another trip
I know my life is so busy
Thank you very much
I'm in Kuala Lumpur
This place looks amazing
Me and Marzia just slept like
20 hours * laughs *
from jet lag
but we're finally ready to head out
I think we're gonna go
there somewhere (Marzia makes a noise in the background)
What are you doing?
Get out of here
Go back to the cage
Stupid
* whispering * It's our anniversary
We're in the park
That's our hotel
I kinda want to jump in
And now we're gonna go...
it's so f-ing hot
Jesus Christ
We're gonna check out
that bridge
The tower was closed today
so we're gonna go tomorrow instead
I feel like I'm in the jungle
* laughs *
So now we're going to the aquarium
Oh my god, this is amazing!
Look at all this, this is just a park
I just got recognized as well
We've been trying to keep this--
us being here
a secret
Because I know I have a lot uh...
a lot of bros here
And I'm actually really scared of getting mobbed
Especially since last time, I was in Singapore
Uh...
It went way out of hand
* laughs *
But yeah, this is so cool
My god, that is terrifying!
It's like slime coming down
Hi...
Ugh...
Oh my god
I don't like this one
Oh, it's looking at my crotch
Oh, no
Ooooh, no
Sooo cute
I like these more than the snake
Oh my god, that's disgusting
They look like Jack's penis
Weeeell I guess there's no fish around here
I can't seem to see any of the fishes
These are so freaky
Ugh, too many tentacles, man
* silly voice * Hey guys, what's goin' on here?
Whatcha doin'?
* weird noise *
This is some alien sh*t
Ugh...
* more weird noises *
We are on
a treadmill
It's going so fast
Oh my god, it scared me!
It literally scared me!
Ah, oh my god, they're everywhere
Marzia
I found you
Well, I think this one ate too much
That is some sexy sh*t
I just took a sh*t
And there's this thing
And I wanted to vlog
it going up my butthole
*stares innocently*
I gotta lean back
Nope
*uh*
There we go
They have this tunnel to walk
*Marzia's appearance*
You don't have to worry--
Thank you, Marzia
It's amazing!
You can just get anywhere!
Now we're gonna check out some shopping
Holy sh*t
It's Fashion Week?
Oh, we're here for Fashion Week
* loud Fashion Week music*
Totally my jam
Love this
Now everyone is going to write comments about that butt
I'm sorry
Okay
So, we're looking for Japan town
while we're in Malaysia
*laughs*
Alriiiiiight
We found it!
This is how they drive in Malaysia
This is how they drive in New York
My favourite vinyl figure...
Steve Jobs
I think we're about to die
'Cos the light's not working
Okay, this is good
Traffic here is a little crazy
So, if I haven't announced it already...
the next PewDiePie game is coming out very soon
It's been in development for...
almost a year
It is rrrrrreally cool
I burped while I said it, so you know it's legit
It's called PewDiePie Tuber Simulator
And it will be a free game for your phone
We wanted to call it Youtuber Simulator
but we weren't allowed for legal reasons
It's really weird
Uh, I know there's been a lot of
"Youtuber Simulator" type of games lately
But we--
like I said,
We've had this game in development for over a year now
before all these other ones came out
We thought it was okay because
this game is so different
Like, it's the same concept but it's such a different game
It's just a really fun game
And I'm happy
that we made a free game
Because that was the biggest feedback
that we got for, um, PewDiePie: Legend of the Brofist
It's Outerminds who made it as well
same developer
You can tell, again, they did an amazing job
because the game is sooo, so great
It's a very creative game
so I'm really excited to see you--
what you Bros are gonna, um, make of it
Yeah, that's all for now
We picked, like, the gloomiest day
But it's very cool!
Oh my god, it's just so weird, we're moving
The whole tower is moving!
Can you tell?
It's so hard to tell, though!
You can barely tell!
Oooh, okay, the tower isn't moving
we are moving
Marzia: No, just-- yeah
Okay
* laughs *
This is scary
Oh my god
Okay, let's get some food
You finding anything good?
Marzia:Yeah.
You spying on naked people in hotels?
Marzia: Naked people * laughs *
That's where we went
It looks like a giant disco ball
What are you doing, Marzia?
Marzia: Waddup? * laughs *
Okay, we're going for a late--
--late afternoon swimmin'
It's so f***ng hot
Even at night, it's so hot
Woah, this is a really nice pool
And there's no one around
* splish splash *
Ooooooh, that feels goooooood
I feel pretty good right now * laughs *
It's a very nice place
Guess where I will come from
Marzia: Okay
Okay?
Marzia: Yep
Left or right?
Marzia: * laughing * What?
*Felix's viking laugh*
*both laughing*
Marzia: um
* kiss *
Marzia: oh
That was for Marzia, not you
Marzia; Wow!
*stramge noises*
Marzia: No, no! I'm gonna drop your phone!
* gasps *
Oops * laughs *
Sorry, oops
You know, there is water right here. Right there
Its waterproof.
What !?
No!
*underwater water*
* laughs *
Oh my god, so unnecessary!
* laughing * That was pretty unnecessary
Day two in Kuala Lumpur
Today we're gonna do some, uh...
museumeming?
There's a lot of cool places around this area
Erm, we're starting with this one
*cute wave*
Do you wanna go on the escalator?
This looks really good
I guess we'll walk
We decided to walk to the next park
and I'm starting to think it was a bad idea
This is crazy
Oh, god
We're going there
This area feels so weird
'cause there is no one around
And I kinda don't really know where we are
* laughs *
But hopefully we'll make it there
We're about to enter the jurassic pa-- bird park
the bird park
Oh my god
* background bird noises *
Alright
Thank you
I spotted some birds
Hii
*Hi poods*
They're like,  people, f this place
Look, Marzia
Lovebirds
She literally didn't hear me * laughs *
Look at that!
That's awesome
Oh my god, what is happening
Oh, they spit!
* silly voice * Hi guys, what's going on?
Heyyy
Meh
This is a squid-
WOW!
What happened?
Aaaah!
* laughs *
Legit got scared
Woooow
Look at you
Fancy
* silly voice * I've got a fooking stick
You better not touch me, man
'Cause I got a stick
* silly voice * Your channel sucks, by the way
There's too many birds
Too much to take in
Oh my god
This is so cool
Look at that guy
Looking very wise
And this one
He's got his own little house going
Marzia: look at that one!
Oooh! Even that one!
So cute! :3
It looks so happy.
They even got freaking eagles
What birds do the not have?
(smth about following that bird outside to reach happiness)
What did you find?
Oh my God.
*Marzia laugh*
This scare me
Heeey!
How u doing?
*brave poods laughs*
*in silly voice* Hiii, what's up?
Is it sleeping?
How're you doing?
Oh. Heyyyy!
Oh, not to close.Thank you.
*beautiful water splashes or how is it called I dunno*
It's pretty though
I'm a little scared
'cause these birds look a little bit scary
But I wanna go and say hi
To my friend
Jacksepticeye here
I wanna touch you if you don't touch me
He look like he could take out my eye if he wanted to
That's why I'm wearing these, by the way
This guy is just like WUT? (bird in coolvoice)
Who u focking are?
U talking to me man?
I should just go
I'm ebaressing myself
Thaat's right u better keep walking
That's right
U better focking keep walking, biitch
Nooow
We are finally gonna go to the towers
Bana!! (?) (That's Petronas towers i think)
I don't know if it's even worth it
since we saw the view yesterday
Whenever I see someone else blonde here I'm like, what are u doing?
I'm the only one blonde one in Kuala Lumpur
Not even blonde *joke cough**
Wooow
Can you see the park?
Look at that!
So we're gonna go eve higher up
Twicw as high as this...and a bit
I'm on top of the world
Mrhm
We are now at the very top
But I haven't seen the view yet
Ooooh!
We are reeeeally high right now
This is a little scary
to be this high
Oh my God!
I feel sick
I feel like we are moving
I don't know
Feel like I need to hold to something
Look how tiny the people down there are
This view really is amazing
We are back
We're gonna chill by the pool again
We are getting recognized so much
Like I said we didn't tell anyone we'll be coming
because we were a little scared about it
people are deffinatly picking up that we are here
like, it's most of my tweets is about, like, WHERE"S HE?!
WHERE"S PODIPIE?!
HE"S IN MALAYSIA. I KNOW HE'S IN MALAYSIA
And I'm still worried that it's goona get out of hand because
I, erm, I get Singapore flashbacks
The first been okay but
we had to stop a lot of times today
A lot  of people don't want just one picture
They want like 3 pictures with different angles
And we're just kinda like, you're not the first one we've met
Okay, that's all *kiss*
okay, I Hope my phone is not gonna break and ruin all the footage
But I'm gonna show Marzia underwater
*underwater*
*Mermaid Poods*
We are at time square something
It's really cool because they have this freaking indoor rollercoaster
Which I've seen on a picture before but it's really really crazy
Oh my God
They have a freaking loop
Thats awesome
I will go on it for sure. I have to go
Thats crazy
The video does not do this place just it. It's really cool
Shoul I go on it, Marzia?
Marzia: yeah ;3
Okay, I think I'll go on it
I'll buy a ticket
*crazy ride sounds*
That was like the unsafest rollercoaster I've ever felt
I got scared because I though I would die
OH, it's on
We're doing the cars
This feels like a theme park with no people - oh my God
*laughs* Marzia
Agh! I don't like this! *laughs* (he likes this)
This is so f*cked
Agh! You crazy!!
I was gonna be nice and not hit you!
What's happening?
No!
My car is not moving
No, please!
Agh! *Go, Marzia!*
Marzia's car went into flames when she drove it
I told you this park is crazy!
There is so no security
There is literally noone here
Marzia: yeah, we are the only one
There is noone, on any of the rides
Okay, well, what shoud we do now?
I don't know
Marzia: what about the trains?
Why I'm need to put on my seatbelt?
Marzia: oh, there are seatbelts?
*laughs* yeah
Marzia: uh
This is so cool. I love this ride. This is my favourite ride.
I love it. I love dancing so much. It makes me feel good, it makes me feel incredible
Okay, last day in Kuala Lumpur
We are going to the Batu caves which is one of the holiest India places outside of India
Let's check it out!
Okay, so we have 272 steps to-
*car honks*
and I gotta move
We're gonna walk all the way out. That's a golden statue. Not a big deal. There's a loser tryin to vlog
It's really hot. It doesn't show in the video but it's really hot
I'm really excited. This is so different
How big is it? look at that, that's crazy!
Time to begin the steps. The walk begins now
Oh no!
You can rent a scarf?
I like the reference pictures. Business women.
Marzia is getting tied up.
This are very stiff steps. Very small and very high.
Willl we be able to make it up there? Oh my God that does- that feels a lot more right now
*laughs* I feel like I could fall backwards
At any moment. I got you, Marzia, don't worry.
Good exercise, for sure
See people stopping, taking breaks on the way
Look we barely gone anywhere *laughs*
We'll make it
I'm sure
Almost there
This is so cool
There is a chiken
*laughs* allright
There is a temple
I guess we'll walk here
Oh, there is monkeys
Look at that!
Dude! Don;t trust it one second
This is how it looks like
It's very cool
But my favourite thing is chiken
Oh man, I didn't even look at the temple
It's like there's a cow
Spiders
On second thought, maybe i won't go into the cave.
Now we're just gonna walk all the way down
It's said that it was gonna rain every single day we came here
Marzia: and it didn't!
And it didn't! Until now
It's raining. Oh my God it's soooo much water!
It's barely raining but we are kinda into it
Marzia: i like it! it's romaaantiiic
Once again we're going to the towers
for cinema as you do in another country
To bad you are not coming, bitch
We're leaving Kuala Lumpur today
This little one got sicky last night
We had to call a doctor
Marzia: really bad, yeah
At 3 a.m.
It's so much more quiet now
Like the weekend was crazy, we really felt like everyone was hunting to find us here
And it's barely anyone and it feels so much more relaxed
It's time to end this vlog. Malaysia, I had such a great time!
Such a cool city - Kuala Lumpur. I really really enjoed it!
This is probably a bit longer vlog-
dude, we have so much traffic ahead of us. Jesus!
I hope you've enjoyed it even though it's alittle bit, a little bit longer
Thanks to all the really nice fans that we met in Malaysia
Shout out to all the Malaysian bros! You guys are intense *laughs*
Leave a like if you want more vlogs like this and I'llbe sure to vlog whenever I go somewhere
And thanks for watching *brofist*
Stay awesome, bros *you too, Felix*
I have the glasses *cute*
I bet you thought the vlog was over
Our flight got canceled
It's 4 in the morning
Marzia: 4:30
4:30
Our flight was supposed to go at 11
Which is like late enough allready
We waited 3 hours
British airways, by the way
I want my money back!
And begged apology!
This is so crazy. I understand things get wrong but
noone knew how to deal with it
like noone told us what to do
Noone told us anything
I've booked us in on another flight with another airline
Which is in 5 hours
So we're gonna spend the nigh at the airport
The other option was to sit on the bus
And i called the British airways and they couldn't tell me anything, they couldn't say anything
They said there wasn't even a flight tommorow
And we really need to go back because
our dog sitter needs to,um, can't take care of the dogs anylonger
It's such a huuuge problem because they canceled this flight
But we will make it back home
It's so crazy. I was getting fully triggered for once
Looks like, um, we are sharing a bed tonight
we tried to stay at hotel so we could sleep at least couple hours but it was full
So we're staying here for- I don't know
*laughs* I'm so tired
I took a sleeping pill * oh poods*
And the plane was supposed to leave 6 hours ago
*laughs*
I can't
I'm so tired
This has been a nightmare
We've been here for almost 10 hours
British airways f*cked it up
*Laughs*
Marzia: big
Big time!
We've been so desparate trying to get- go home
The flight that I booked was canceled
I don't- like everything just gone wrong
but we've managed to get on a flight. Thanks to paying a lot of money *tired laugh*
And Marzia
Marzia: hehe
erm 'cause my card didn't work
we're going home now. Tht's all that matters
F*ck British airways
Honestly, all airlines. They all suck
Like, this could have beem any airline
*happy pugs with daddy poods*
Stop